la sangre es roja
la vimos salir por una herida y es roja
5 litros de sangre roja recorren nuestro
cuerpo de noche y de día dormidos y
despiertos entran al corazón salen del
corazón recorren todo el cuerpo
células que viajan por un líquido
escurridizo transportando el oxígeno los
nutrientes cataratas por donde viaja
nuestra inmunidad
la sangre tiene que llegar al rincón más
escondido
y nos conecta desde antes de nacer
porque viaja por el cordón umbilical de
la mamá al bebé
y las fabricamos solo nosotros
no se consigue producir artificialmente
no hay innovación científica y
tecnológica que pudo reproducir las
funciones de estas células tan precisas
y tan preciosas a la escala que nosotros
la necesitamos
pero hay una buena noticia somos muy
eficientes produciéndola somos una
máquina de vida en vida
sin pensarlo sin esfuerzo nuestro cuerpo
es una fábrica
cada segundo cada uno de nosotros libera
de la médula ósea la circulación
millones de glóbulos rojos por segundo
producimos algo muy valioso y podemos
hacerlo circular
lo que no se sabe mucho es que la sangre
es un elemento muy usado para curar se
usa todos los días y en cada hospital es
imprescindible para que las personas
puedan operarse puedan transcurrir sin
ciertas enfermedades crónicas o
oncológicas hasta situaciones más
críticas que ponen en riesgo su vida
sin sangre los hospitales no pueden
funcionar
y en argentina tenemos dos problemas uno
es que todavía dependemos de los
donantes que le pedimos a los pacientes
y el otro que de ese sistema de pedir
donantes depende en parte la calidad y
la seguridad de la sangre que tenemos
para ofrecer
en general nos conectamos con la sangre
cuando un amigo o con un familiar lo
necesita cuando circula un pedido
desesperado en las redes o en los medios
cuando en circunstancias puntuales
sabemos que alguien necesita un donante
pero a mí la sangre me conecto con el
hospital garraham
cuando termine mi paciencia de pediatría
mi sueño era entrar en el hospital no
importaba qué servicio yo quería estar
ahí
hice una mañana y vi un cartel que decía
beca de formación en hemoterapia
eso no sabía que se hacía en un banco de
sangre pero fui a la entrevista y ahí
quedé
claro cuando entré me di cuenta
que había entrado al corazón del
hospital al servicio que tiene la
responsabilidad de bombear la sangre a
todos los pacientes que la necesitan
y mi primer día de trabajo y recibo a
una mamá de una paciente que tenía una
cirugía programada por un tumor de riñón
le había mandado el cirujano para
hacerse los estudios pre quirúrgicos y
además para ver cómo hacía para traer
sus donantes
la mamá estaba angustiada porque no
sabía cómo llevarse erizo
intuitivamente le dije que se quedara
tranquila que sea nuestro problema era
nuestra obligación y nosotros nos íbamos
a ocupar de eso
la madre se fue
y una compañera me dio el primer baño de
realidad me explicó cómo eran las cosas
si la mamá no traía los donantes era
difícil asegurarle la sangre para el día
de la cirugía
ahí entendí cómo era el sistema
para quien viene a donar le
preguntábamos a cada donante cuando se
acercaban a la ventanilla y los
anotábamos prolijamente eran nuestros
donantes de reposición venían ligados al
nombre de un paciente
nos atendemos en el hospital desde las 7
de la mañana hasta las 12 del mediodía
después procesamos la sangre de los
distintos componentes los glóbulos rojos
las plaquetas el plasma la analizábamos
y la dejábamos lista para ser
transfundida para cuando un paciente la
necesitaba
todo sucedía muy ordenadamente era un
sistema prolijo y bancario
pero estábamos en un lugar de altos
estándares donde siempre queremos
ofrecer la mejor calidad de atención a
todos nuestros pacientes y en el caso
del banco de sangre es la mejor calidad
de sangre posible aquella que hace su
efecto terapéutico pero que además no
ocasiona daño entre otras cosas no
transmite infecciones
entonces desde un principio
implementamos un sistema de gestión de
calidad basado en buenas prácticas de
manufactura siguiendo estándares
internacionales
en un momento incorporamos unas pruebas
que se llaman de biología molecular para
detectar muy tempranamente aquellos
virus que pueden transmitirse por
transfusión
vivos fascinados como nuestros
indicadores de calidad mejoraban a
medida que empezábamos a captar nuestros
primeros donantes voluntarios aquellos
donantes que no vienen relacionados para
un paciente
pero llegó un momento que la sangre que
contábamos dejó de mejorar llegó una
meseta se estancó
a pesar de haber llegado al 35 por
ciento donantes voluntarios había un 5
por ciento de sangre que teníamos que
tirar que era inservible que estaba
infectada
algo no estaba bien
y la verdad es que nos sentíamos
incómodos
enseguida supimos dónde estaba el
problema
el problema estaba en el sistema pero no
en el sistema tecnológico ni en los
procesos de análisis el problema estaba
en el sistema por el cual los donantes
se acercaban a donar y más
específicamente en su motivación
en un punto venían para cubrir para
cubrir un cupo
algunos presionados
muchos se sentían obligados a omitir
información importante cuando le
hacíamos la entrevista que le hacemos a
todos los donantes para ver si pueden
donar o no para ver si son aptos
algunos no nos contaban cuestiones
importantes relacionadas con su salud o
se habían estado expuesto a alguna
situación de riesgo para transmitir
estas infecciones por la sangre
porque no se podían dar el lujo de no
donar no podían arriesgarse a que no
operen a su hijo a su nieto oa su
sobrina
y porque es importante saber si un
donante estuvo pasó por alguna situación
de riesgo porque por más que nosotros
analizamos toda la sangre en el
laboratorio
si el donante está en una etapa muy
temprana de la enfermedad no la podemos
detectar entonces ponemos a
disponibilidad sangre con un riesgo
potencial de hacerle un daño a un
paciente
si bien en un momento parecía muy cómodo
pedirle a los pacientes que trajeran los
donantes donantes la verdad que no era
nada cómodo más en nuestro hospital
porque porque nuestro hospital es un
hospital de referencia nacional y además
es un hospital pediátrico entonces se
hace más evidente lo que en otros
lugares quizás no están visibles
nosotros no le podemos pedir a un bebé a
un nene tráeme diez donantes
tampoco es bueno pedírselo a la mamá que
tiene que estar cuidando a su hijo
mucho menos a una familia que viene por
ejemplo de tucumán que no conoce a nadie
no tiene red no tiene quien la juve
si nosotros queríamos poner al paciente
en el centro y hacer prevalecer su
derecho a ser atendido tratado
no debíamos involucrarlo en una tarea
que para él no solamente era angustiante
sino muy compleja
y estábamos nosotros detrás de la
ventanilla
intentando resolver el problema con las
mismas personas que tienen el problema
en un círculo cerrado teníamos que salir
y esa incomodidad fue sana
nos empujó porque había una alternativa
que es la opción de un sistema con
donantes 100% voluntarios algo que
sabíamos que funcionaba en otras partes
del mundo pero que no sabíamos que podía
pasar en argentina porque ningún lugar
de sudamérica lo tiene
teníamos miedo de no abastecer nos miedo
de no tener sangre suficiente porque
íbamos a empezar a depender de personas
que donarán para otras sin estar
condicionadas por un pedido
teníamos que dejar atrás un formato
conocido de trabajo para pasar una
organización más compleja debíamos
asegurarnos sangre todo el año porque la
sangre se vence entonces había que salir
a buscar los donantes los feriados los
fines de semana largo las vacaciones
y para eso tenemos que decidir invertir
mucho en planificación pero también en
recursos
lo que sí estábamos seguros es que
queríamos ofrecer una sangre de la mayor
calidad y seguridad posible y que además
queríamos pasar un sistema en donde la
sangre está esperando al paciente y no
al revés
y nos animamos y buscamos como excusa
una fecha simbólica que fue el 14 de
junio del año 2011 cuando argentina fue
sede del día mundial del donante de
sangre
ese día hicimos un pequeño cambio que
generó una transformación enorme
desde ese día dejamos de preguntarle a
cada donante para quién venía a donar
empezamos a atender hasta las 6 de la
tarde les avisamos a todos los médicos
que no mandarán más los pacientes para
ver cómo hacían con los donantes y
empezamos a hacer con más frecuencia
campañas de donación o colectas externas
de sangre
lo que nunca nos imaginamos era que
conseguir donantes no iba a ser el
principal problema
ese fantasma que nos acechaba no existe
la cultura de la donación no apareció
cuando íbamos a las universidades a las
empresas a los municipios a los clubes
nos dicen que si organizar colectas de
sangre claro ayudar a salvar tres vidas
en un ratito
nos dimos cuenta que la gente no piensa
no donó para nadie
pensamos dono para el que lo necesita
esa asociación entre donantes y
pacientes era un prejuicio que estaba
solo en nuestra cabeza
claramente la principal dificultad
fuimos nosotros mismos tuvimos que
cambiar rutinas de trabajo aprender
nuevas habilidades adaptarnos a la
incertidumbre porque cuando salimos a
una colecta es como una excursión al
mundo no sabemos qué va a pasar
cuántas personas nos van a esperar cómo
los vamos a organizar dónde vamos a
comer
tuvimos que dejar de ser trabajadores de
hospital para pasar a ser líderes
comunitarios
lo que sí sabemos es que cuando llegamos
nos reciben con mucha alegría y con
mucha expectativa y los organizadores le
ponen toda la creatividad y todo el
esfuerzo para que la colecta sea el
evento solidario del año donde nosotros
somos los embajadores del hospital
y nuestra actitud todos los días tienen
que ser distintas
cinco años después podemos decir que lo
logramos que estamos abastecidos 100%
gracias a nuestros donantes voluntarios
sin tener que pedirle ningún donante a
ningún paciente
y que la calidad de nuestra sangre
mejoró en 10 veces porque es desde ese
5% que teníamos de infecciones pasamos a
tener un 0.5 por ciento
y además
y además logramos formar un equipo de
trabajo capaz de sostener día a día este
corazón que bombea la sangre a todo el
hospital
con el tiempo me di cuenta que gran
parte del éxito había tenido que ver con
lo que habíamos aprendido de la ciencia
de la tecnología de la planificación
estratégica pero que el verdadero cambio
sucedió cuando pudimos aprender
habilidades de otros campos que no son
ni de la biología ni de la medicina
porque para hablar de sangre hay que
mirar a los ojos de persona a persona
porque antes que nos conecta la sangre
nos conecta la palabra
y aprendimos en redes sociales y hablar
en la radio y diseñar encuestas
descubrimos que la importancia de la
donación como muchas otras cosas se
aprenden en la escuela y ahora los
chicos son partes de talleres en el aula
o en el hospital y organizando colectas
y viendo a sus maestros a sus padres
donar se convierten en promotores y en
futuros donantes
entendimos que la gente sana no quiere
ni necesita ir al hospital y que muchas
veces eso funciona como una barrera por
eso instalamos la donación en los
lugares de todos los días donde las
personas se estudian trabajan o se
divierten cuando llegamos una colecta
nos esperan entre 25 y 150 personas que
donan cuando salen del aula en un recreo
después de mandar un mail en la oficina
debajo de un árbol o cuando se suban a
nuestro móvil de donación
y cuando esa experiencia es buena
ahí sucede la magia
porque se abren nuevos círculos y esos
donantes se convierten en organizadores
de otras colectas en otros espacios
donde participan
los padres agradecidos también organizan
colectas
este cambio fue disruptivo para el
sistema de salud pública en argentina y
en la región
y cuando probamos que era posible en un
hospital público intentamos que se
promoviera en otros lugares y es así que
el año pasado el ministerio de salud de
la nación emitió una resolución en la
cual prohíbe la exigencia de donantes a
nuestros pacientes y que somos las
instituciones junto con la comunidad
quienes tenemos que salir a buscarlos
irá en búsqueda del donante salir del
hospital te cambia la mirada
te permite escucharte y salir dejar ese
lugar de esperar que algo pase que
alguien venga
cuando pudimos salir de nuestro pequeño
círculo logramos construir un nuevo
modelo de corazón para hospital
y mi sueño y el de muchos es que en toda
la argentina haya un corazón para todos
[Aplausos]